[Music]
I'm very pleased to welcome and thank
all of you for coming to the Nobel Prize
dialogue Tokyo today's dialogue focuses
on the topic the future of intelligence
it is thought that understanding the
scientific understanding they have to go
together in tandem every time we have a
computer revolution we change the way we
interact with computers and now it looks
like we're at another transition point
we're moving into an age where we're
going to be first of all talking to it
conversing and it'll be much more of a
conversation rather than a question
answer hi I did Elena
I think meetings like these are great
specifically because they are across
disciplines I'm a chemical engineering
student interesting brain science I
think the number of prior dialogues are
a lot of fun but most of all I hope they
encourage young students to get really
excited about science and go on and do
great things great even I have come from
India it is a really great chance for us
so we are happy again we needed I found
this style of very are very relevant and
very informative and very
thought-provoking the question is
whether one day a robot could be joining
the ranks of the Nobel laureate let's
hope these robots are interested in
receiving the Nobel Prize for science to
be understood and respected in society
it's necessary that time to communicate
what they do and it may be more
important now than ever we use machines
and in forms of AI to augment supplement
our human intelligence and the
compensate make our civilization more of
well I don't know what's going to happen
in AI but I do know it's going to have
profound effects not only within the
high-tech industry but for all of
society it's one of the most exciting
fields of human endeavor
[Music]